bill cosby could spend the rest of his
life behind bars for a sexual assault
conviction that his front page news in
his hometown paper the philadelphia
inquirer actually it's front page news
all around the country a jury found the
80 year old comedian guilty of drugging
and molesting andrea constand back in
2004 Cosby faces up to 30 years in
prison he will appeal the verdict and is
still free on bail he is the first
celebrity to be convicted in the era of
the me2 movement Adriana Diaz is outside
the courthouse in Norristown
Pennsylvania with more on this story
Adriana good morning good morning when
the bombshell verdict was read some of
Cosby's accusers in the courtroom
shrieked with relief it took jurors just
14 hours to convict the man once known
as America's dad three of the more than
60 Cosby accusers walked out of the
Pennsylvania Court rule Thursday shaking
with emotion following the guilty
verdict accuser Lily Barnard was there
for every day of the two-week trial it
was a long and emotional trial for the
women who were defeated less than a year
ago when another jury deadlocked on the
same charges against Cosby the trial
focused on andrea constand who accused
Bill Cosby of drugging and molesting her
at his Philadelphia home 14 years ago
Cosby's always maintained that his
relationship with constand was
consensual five other women testified
that Cosby also assaulted them I feel
free I feel free one of those women was
salon lasha who claims Cosby drugged and
sexually assaulted her in a hotel room
when she was 17 years old she said the
verdict is vindicating I'm glad that the
truth is out I didn't have a billion
dollars I only had the truth shortly
after the verdict was read the district
attorney argued Cosby is a flight risk
and should be thrown in jail
Cosby lashed out and called him an
a-hole and a jury has spoken with one
voice district attorney Kevin Steele we
hope that this case sends a strong
message
that the victims of these types of
crimes can come forward and be heard
Cosby's defense says it will appeal we
don't think mr. Cosby is guilty of
anything and the fight is not over just
hours after the verdict three more
universities rescinded Cosby's honorary
degrees he had to forfeit his passport
and he can't leave the county until his
sentencing which is expected in 60 to 90
days john adriana thanks